这个9块9块9块扣3扣3
9块扣个三
兄这么小抱不住
来这个9块钱9块9块小马甲扣三扣三这个9块扣个三
来这个这个是大家的这个大家的这个短袖这个小短袖这个我留了两件
冰冰凉凉的这种触感触感
面料很软很柔软的胸胃104130长度460这个9块9块扣个5
9块钱9块钱扣5扣5啊
嗯大家的大家的这一款9块9块扣5扣5啊
来这一款这个这个是这个上衣是一个小外套两边有鞋扎口袋的这个是
两边是鞋扎口袋
然后这个标的是啊一个几码lo吃满了巨脂75棉25
巨脂75棉25牌子是这个牌子的这个牌来这个尺寸量一下的
胸围胸围106106124106124胸围长度长度75
长度75然后外面是一个嗯墨绿色外面是一个墨绿色里面是一个灰色
这样一个小外套而且这个面料还有弹力很舒服两边是口袋
前面是一个大拉链的这个29块扣个5
29扣个5这个后面的话他是打改的这种后面下摆的话是打改的这个大翻领子
2929扣5扣5
29块扣个5
来这个这个是一个粉色粉色的一条哈伦裤
粉色一条哈伦裤两边有鞋扎都来这个腰围腰围66-706670
腿围104116
肛肠37裤肠95这个给你们9块钱9块9块扣个5粉色粉色一条哈伦裤
九元九元扣5扣5
66-70个腰9块钱扣5扣5
9块9块扣个5
还有一边
一块钱扣个5这个马甲又出来一个了这个原来是29一直卖29的
来给你们9块了这个不多了这个9块9块扣0扣0
9块钱扣个0
来这一条
这条紫色的一条大裤子里的一条裤
裤子里的一条裤这是啥
啊这是一个线头回去给他修一下就行了
这个没有标没看见是啥标后半边送你呢腰围64-88
6488腿围腿围112120当场40裤长92
那这个咱没有腰的扣这个39裤2
紫色紫色的一条大裤的一裤
39块
扣2扣2这一条
板线很好
后半边松紧的这一条紫色的
来这个39块
扣2扣2
39扣个2
收起来
C15
verk
33捐纸3
这个这个牌
全松拟
卡铁
腰围68 98
腿围110 126
当场36
裤长98
拿这个有药的39
扣8
39块
扣8扣8这一条
棉婚纺
棉就是捐纸的
来这个39块
扣8扣8
卡齐卡齐色的这一条
39 39扣8扣8
39块
来这个全棉100的一个小吊带
牌子这个牌
棉100棉100的这个牌子的
然后是一个全棉100的一个L尺码
袋子可以随意调节
这个上面全是斯马克松拟的这个
全可以随意调节的
来这个胸围
胸围的话是
22到110
长度大概是55的一个长度
55的一个长度
这个有药的扣
来这个29
29扣1
29块这个地方有一点
微黄有一点点微黄回去给它洗洗
黑吧应该黑了有点点
有点黑黑的有点黄黄的19了19了
不介意的扣2扣2
19块
扣2扣2
全棉100
这个一直卖29的有一点点脏了给你们19块了
19块
扣个2回去洗洗就掉了
1919不介意的扣2
19块来这一款M码一个锯纸
这是啥牌子
M码M码的一个锯纸
来这个
后面是裙半双拧滑包腰的
这样一条扣
哈林裤哈林裤的这一条
然后前面有分离扣有拉链
腰围68 68 92
68 92
腿围
当场35
裤长91
来这个29块
这个底下有一点微狭
脏了一点
这个给你们29块
扣1扣1
29 29
不介意的扣1
还送了一个扣子呢
29扣1扣1
这里裤腿这里有一点点脏
29块
扣1扣1
我得来处理一下
这一包都是裤的
一包这几件都裤
来这一条
这个S码
S码棉72尼龙25
居然是3
SHO的
这个牌子
S码S码一个白色的
腰围
腰围是66 66能拉伸80
腿围
腿围92 110
当场34
裤长88
这个39扣8
39块
扣8扣8S码
39 39
扣8扣8这一块
扣8扣8S码
哦不对
那个
小马的一条裤子
我这么烫的
你也学什么事
那你女儿选什么科
还不知道呢
我们这到高一的下半学期才选科呢
应该选什么好我也不知道
来这一个
你们家选的什么化学
物理
不化生吗还有啥
你刚说啥我都给忘了
为什么打电话给你
那为什么打电话给我
去报志愿呀
报志愿你就是报哪个学校
想上哪个学校
先是这样子的
比如说我们这里有一中二中
三中四中然后还加上两个
还有其他几个私立学校
我报了一个二中还有
昨天就是选学校去了
看他分数能不能录上
能录上二中吧
应该二中他还想去我还不想让他去
那个立家太远了
五六公里呢
我知道你们有中年学校
就是选学校去选科的话要在高一的下学期才选科
你们那现在就选科了
无化生呗
选
来这个腰围
腰围64
64到86
腿围
腿围98 116
肝肠38
哭肠98
来这个39哭8你们那咋这么早就选了开始
我们高一下学期才选的
8月十几号
7月20号左右那个通知书就能下来了
然后到8月十几号就开始开学
去军训吧
军训十来天
两个礼拜应该差不多
才开的正式上课
大概基本上都是这个过程
来这个
然后上上一个学期先下学期才开始选科
现在不选
来这个3939扣3
39块扣3扣3
正常过程就是这样子的
39块
扣3扣3a
你们咋这么早就开始选了
高中
还没去上呢就选科了已经
高中都还没去上呢
就开始选了
我们这里
下学期才选
来这个4L的一个句子
黑色黑色的这个大阔腿
4L尺码大两边有写查口袋的这个块来一个腰围
腰围84
84能拉伸到112
腿围
腿围128134
当场
当场39
当场39裤长95
中三都教高中的了
我天哪
咋这么快呢
中三都教高中了已经
那你学的太快了
所以呢天呐
来这个这个29给你们29
尺码大
扣1扣1
29扣1
难怪你们那里都这么厉害提前都学完了
我们没有没有没有学会了
现在放假这个时间多少代价自己学吧
还不干天天刷手机天天睡大觉的我能叫气死天天
来这个侧边有拉链
有拉链有风机扣这一块
直筒直筒的这一条
前面有几个装饰的扣子后半边松你
来这个腰围68到84
腿围
腿围110 118
当场38
裤长98
来这个39
扣8扣8
多大码呢这个
这个版型好看没有标
这个没洗标
没写
70平坡
哎不对
这个68
68到84的腰
68 84的腰
L号应该差不多
文科你就不知道了
有大一点的不
这个就是一条好像这个版型
68到84的腰这个
来这个39
扣个1
39扣1
版型不一定有
没有
就那一个
一个款一件
都是孤瓶灰色灰色
XM嘛
L号的70以上平坡
那差不多
没有
后半边松你加欧为一的这个有个
盘但是水起标没看见
加欧为一的呢
能穿吗
灰色灰色的这个是
没有没有标
水起标没有只有一个主起标
加欧为一这个版型好看
没有就这一条你看都是孤瓶现在裤子
再找第二条都不好找
来这个这个是L号巨是75人年18居然是7这个牌这个牌
这个牌子的
来这个标的塞露什么了
腰围
腰围72
72能拉伸100
72 100
凭位
凭位是108118当场
当场35
扣上93
来这个39
扣3
39扣3人民会访的这个
阿伦库
39 39扣3扣3
就那一条
这个就那一条
啥
来这个M码绵67巨是32居然是1
来这一条裤这个不好就上面有个洞
这个面这个裤子
这个裤子大腿后面有个洞呢
这样子的
这样子的了
香港多人选理科
因为在大学理科能
让文科相反就不能
哦
理科理科选的人比较多
来一个腰围